what about the argument that really ill  baby  so where do you stand on those issues if  you have a two-year-old you find out  they have cancer  or they get in a terrible car accident  and they're just you know  very disfigured or something like that  does that mean it's okay to kill them  and i think the vast majority of people  would say no so the same applies for a  child in the womb i mean the reality is  birth does not suddenly transfer human  humanity to you  you're human before and after birth our  life starts at the moment of  fertilization and then you just need  time and nourishment to grow  unless something interrupts your growth  which could be an act of violence  against you  so if the baby's disabled that baby  deserves even more care